elon musk has been a republican for less
than 48 hours and already they are me
tooing him that's right already they are
accusing him of sex crimes
i think that's a new record
elon musk has been around
for half a century now
he has been in public life since the
late 1990s he has been prominent in
public life for what 20 years now
and just now just
24 hours after announcing that he's
become a republican the establishment
media run a shocking story that six
years ago elon musk propositioned a
masseuse or something
elon actually predicted that this would
happen a couple of days ago he said
expect the political attacks against me
to escalate in the coming months
and because the establishment
propagandists are so predictable we get
this first one almost immediately
all of a sudden for whatever reason
whatever reason who knows six years
after the alleged incident
this poor beleaguered masseuse has just
seen fit to bring this traumatic
experience to light just coincidentally
while elon is in the midst of a hostile
takeover of a major speech platform on
an explicitly anti-leftist political
platform
what are the odds what are the odds i
have a rule in politics
i do not take seriously
any allegation against long-time public
figures especially against political
figures and especially in heated
political moments
that concerns events that supposedly
took place
years prior
the reason is one if the allegations
were legit they likely would have come
out
years prior they would have come out in
the past but also two
because the allegations are so
obviously cynical so obviously
opportunistic at least
even in the unlikely event that whatever
is alleged did actually happen
it is only coming out now to shut the
accused person up or to intimidate the
accused person or to bully the accused
person or to stop him from affecting
whatever kind of political change he's
trying to bring about
in the past when the establishment had
more credibility these sorts of
campaigns worked
today i'm not so sure that they do if
anything frankly i think they might have
the opposite effect
i was previously somewhat on the fence
about elon musk i like the twitter stuff
i like the trolling don't love plugging
your brain into the matrix so i don't
know i was a little bit on the fence
now that he is being hit with some
cynical sex allegation by the worst
people on earth by the news media and
the political hacks in the establishment
i am far more likely to support him
in a world of censorship and media
manipulation it can be hard to judge a
man by his words and even by his actions
but you can still judge a man by his
enemies and right now elon has all the
right ones i'm michael knowles this is
the michael little show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from gamer dad who
said
i knew joe was lying when he said world
leaders walk up to me
no joe nobody walks up to you except the
guy selling ice cream that's true joe
biden can be in a room ostensibly of his
own supporters
and no one wants to talk to him we saw
that very sad video and then everyone's
talking to obama and then biden goes up
to try to say like hey hey obama you
know i'm the president and obama shows
him away says get out of here is it any
wonder that biden is doing such a poor
job handling our economy one reason that
you might want to consider birch gold
right now text knolls to 98 98 98
because it finally happened folks the
fed has realized the dire straits that
our economy is in thanks to our loose
monetary policy turns out you're gonna
be shocked to hear this you can't just
spend trillions of dollars every year
with absolutely no repercussions so to
play catch-up the fed has been raising
rates and plans to raise rates
seven times this year you are already
seeing those ripple effects in the
housing market as people's buying power
diminishes have you considered what
could happen in the stock market if the
economy stalls out do not wait for that
to happen take some of your profits from
the stock market right now and solidify
them with gold from birch gold
throughout history gold has maintained
its value better than any other
investment in the world i personally
very much enjoyed investing in precious
metals and gold specifically text nulls
k wles 298 9898 for a free zero
obligation info kit on holding gold in a
tax sheltered retirement account you
probably wish that you did this about a
week or two ago a month ago maybe but
it's not too late do it now with
countless five star reviews and an a
plus rating uh with the better business
bureau i trust the professionals at
birch gold so text null scan wles and
secure the gains that you have made
while you can
go check out birch gold today
the elon sexual harassment allegation
has so
many layers to it
so what the libs are claiming now
is what all of elon's political
opponents are claiming which is to say
the libs
they're saying
listen the only reason that elon warned
people
that he there were going to be a lot of
political attacks against him the only
reason he came out as a republican the
only reason his championing free speech
and all this is because he knew
he knew that these allegations were
going to come out so he got ahead of the
story
uh okay
yeah maybe the timing is a little
coincidental for me because it's not as
though elon musk woke up one day and
just out of the blue said i'm a
republican now
and then the allegations hit then you
could imagine okay maybe he was tipped
off that the allegations were going to
come out that business insider was going
to run this story and so he just pulled
a publicity stunt
but elon has been setting the stage for
this
for
well over a month now more than well
more than a month
and he's been paddling around with the
babylon bee and he's been cozying up to
conservatives for a very very long time
you're telling me that business insider
was just working on this story the whole
time and and that elon musk is now
putting 44 billion on the table
and and opening himself up to the
securities and exchange commission
opening himself up to all sorts of
political attacks to get ahead of this
story about
propositioning a masseuse i don't buy
that i don't buy that for one second so
there's obviously the political layer to
it
at the most superficial layer this is
about a woman who's seen the light and
says she needs to accuse elon musk six
years after something very vaguely
insinuated maybe happened
then the deeper level is this is
obviously about politics this is
obviously because elon is going against
the liberal establishment so they're
going to turn all the guns on him and
they're going to use their most frequent
method which is me tooing him okay
there's actually a deeper level
potentially even than that there's a
story that came out last night from the
twitter account unusual wales which
posts uh financial activity and they
pointed out
that
coincidentally the day after this
business insider story on elon musk was
published there was a large put option
that was expiring so there was a
the day after the story was published
there was an opportunity
for a big investor to bet against
the tesla
share price
there was an opportunity and it was that
was it that that was going to be the day
that it was going to happen
that uh the that someone could make a
lot of money if the tesla share price
went down
a lot of money an unusual amount of
money
and then just coincidentally the day
before that's to happen business insider
drops this story it gets even crazier
because the ceo of business insider has
been accused of securities fraud and i
think barred from the industry
business insider did the same thing with
barstool right you remember i think it
was business insider that broke that
story someone in the press broke that
story about about dave portnoy and
barstow sports and they metoo'd him as
well
and oddly enough
the same
situation was happening there was an
opportunity the following day to make a
ton of money if
the
price of barstool went down
so what exactly is going on here now
unusual whales did not make any specific
allegations here whether against
business insider or anyone else just
observing that the timing is a little
coincidental in the same way that the
political watchers were observing that
the timing was a little coincidental of
these allegations
so too the financial insiders were
looking at that as well when you're
trying to figure out what is this about
and
you've got in one place
virtue
and then in the next place ideology and
then the next place politics and then
the next place money what is this about
this big new political event
you're usually safe for betting on the
last two
okay a lot of times what happens is that
what corporations or the hack
politicians they will
feign virtue they will signal virtue
they will
they will speak in terms of ideology but
what a lot of it comes down to is cold
hard jockeying for power and cold hard
cash seems to be what's going on here i
don't think it'll work though
it might hurt him i mean any allegation
is damaging that's why people still lob
them but i don't think it'll really hurt
elon with his base i think we see
through this kind of stuff frankly
i am more inclined to support him now
that i see that the entire media
establishment are going after him think
okay well he's got the right enemies
he's got my enemies so i guess he can't
be all bad
this is the usual tricks that we see you
are seeing right now
a whole lot of tricks coming out from
the media establishment especially on
this term du jour
this really this is the the current
thing this week that everyone's talking
about in the media establishment to club
republicans on the head they're talking
about the great replacement theory
and the great replacement theory is this
idea that
uh people in politics are
on the left are using immigration policy
to transform the electorate of the
united states so that they can get an
electoral advantage
i don't know exactly what's
conspiratorial about this or theoretical
i mean they've been bragging about doing
this for 20 years but
they they can't seem to get totally on
message now so on cnn they're talking
about this as though it were some crazy
insane conspiracy theory that only the
most racist bigoted kooky republicans
are are repeating and it's such a
terrible problem we've got to censor
people from from repeating it
over the weekend adam kinzinger
highlighted uh the number three
republican in the house elise stefanik's
use of the white replacement theory in
an ad he wrote uh did you know that
elise stefanik pushes white replacement
theory the number three in the house gop
uh liz cheney got removed for demanding
the truth the republican leader should
be asked about this
it's not just elise stefanik if you
watch fox news this is the mainstay of
their prime time hours tucker carlson
discusses it in sometimes euphemistic
form but not really that all that
euphemistic
what does this country do about the way
in which this idea of white replacement
has just become part of our politics
it's a really really uh tough question
because we don't have you know legal
instruments in this country to restrain
radical speech in that way
we don't have it and he goes on he says
look i'm not calling for it i like free
speech but just it's just we just don't
have the opportunity when people spread
the
replacement conspiracy theory
unfortunately this misinformation
disinformation spreads so that's the
line coming from
cnn
a little bit confusing because the line
coming from the new york times right now
is the opposite the new york times very
same day published a column
saying uh not not denying great
replacement theory but saying no great
great replacement theory is happening
it's always been happening and it's a
very good thing
you know what's a really good thing
good fresh american meat like you get
from good ranchers
right now go to goodranchers.com
knowles you should do this just
generally this would be a good idea if
that were all i were going to tell you
today about good ranchers which brings
top quality meat to your door whenever
you want it
but today's even crazier because when
you place your order with code knowles k
w l e s you will get two pounds of free
wagyu beef which is my favorite thing
that good ranchers puts out and i love
all of their stuff i love the better
than organic chicken i love the new york
strip steaks i love all of it but my
favorite is that wagyu beef so you can
get two pounds right now of the wagyu
beef just for free you can save 25
per month when you subscribe off of
every single box for life and speaking
of for life we've got inflation going on
through our economy right now record
highs you can lock in your price for
meat for life you can inflation proof
your grocery shopping head on over to
goodranchers.com knowles or use code
knowles right now to claim two pounds of
free wagyu burgers and lock in your
subscription price if you do not buy the
meat in your house tell the person who
does to grab two pounds of free american
wagyu beef today before it's gone promo
code knowles goodranchers.com knowles go
check out good ranchers today
the libs need to get on a list serve or
something they need to
sit down have a meeting get on the same
talking points because they are telling
us simultaneously that great replacement
theory is
is fake
it's the most racist kooky
conspiratorial thing anyone's ever heard
and also that it's real and has always
been happening and it's a great thing
this column just came out by brett
stevens who used to be kind of
conservative and now
i don't think one would really call him
a conservative and he's at the new york
times so there you have it
he writes as the first paragraph of the
column
in the broadest sense what goes by the
name replacement theory the idea that
american elites are conspiring to
replace so-called real americans with
immigrants from four countries is merely
a description of the american way
enshrined in tradition codified by law
promoted by successive generations of
american leaders
from washington to lincoln to kennedy
and reagan
he goes on blah blah blah blah
what all of this says is that the
phenomenon of replacement writ large is
america and has been from the beginning
sometimes by force mostly by choice what
the far right calls replacement is
better described as renewal
[Music]
points for half honesty his account of
history is a little weak though he makes
some interesting points in the column
it is not the case as i think brett
stevens is insinuating and as joe biden
said
infamously and explicitly that america
has just been an endless stream of
migration from the very beginning that's
not true we've had laws throughout the
history of our country that
almost shut down immigration for large
periods of time and greatly restricted
immigration and controlled immigration
so as not to upset political balances in
the country for long periods of american
history
and then over the last 50 years we've
completely gotten rid of those
restrictions opened the floodgates to an
immigration regime specifically designed
to give advantage to democrats so that's
just what's happening right now now
you're seeing record immigration not
just at the legal level million legal
immigrants per year but at the illegal
level two million
illegal immigrants per year so three
million total who skew dramatically
democratic now we are seeing some
movement of hispanics into the gop camp
but overall the effect is undeniably in
favor of democrats
and brett stevens says this is renewal
this is renewal so
which is it i'm i'm really torn here
because
if i said on this show if i said on this
show what brett stevens has said if i
said on this show what joe biden has
said
if i said on this show what countless
libs have said on msnbc on cnn
joe scarborough says demographics is
destiny cnn
the new york times the washington post
all saying
yes
even left-wing political scientists that
have been saying this now for 20 years
that yes immigration policy is going to
doom the republican party it the point
of the immigration policy is to
specifically to reduce the percentage of
white voters in america because we the
democrats believe that if we have more
hispanic voters in america and from
other regions too but especially
hispanic voters that that is going to
give us a permanent majority if if i
said that if i made those
substantive claims right now rather than
just merely discussing them in
historical context
my wikipedia page would be changed and
they would say michael knowles is a far
right crazy conspiracy theorist white
supremacist bigot neo-nazi the guy's
worse than adolf hitler
if i just if i just made the exact same
claims that joe biden
now i guess brett stevens
cnn msnbc
all the rest of them
michael anton at the claremont institute
has described this bizarre phenomenon
that we're living in
which which goes actually even a lot
deeper than a replacement or immigration
or anything else we're in a phenomenon
now where the left gets to say something
and then
we repeat the same thing that the left
said
and the left gets angry at us for
repeating it
it's
the comparisons to 1984 i think are
tedious sometimes but here is a place
where it's probably apt
we are being forced to lie we are being
forced to deny what we see with our own
lying eyes and here with our own lying
ears
all the while the left smirks and
contradicts itself and brags about it in
boasts because they have got
the power
which which is it i don't know it's not
it's not happening and it's good that it
is this is that's what we've heard from
from the beginning on so many of these
issues it's not critical race theory is
not being taught in schools and it's
good that it is transgenderism is not
being pushed on little kids and it's
good that it is the replacement theory
replacement migration is not happening
and it's a good thing that it is it's a
renewal because of all you stale
disgusting americans
that you guys are bad the people who are
born in america you guys are bad you're
disgusting you're lazy you're just awful
you're stale you're decaying the country
so we need renewal according to the new
york times so they say why don't we
trust the media
with with such
such honesty as they've shown why don't
we trust the media
glenn greenwald
who is i always thought of him as a
leftist left-wing journalist but he said
some things now that the wright really
likes he put together a phenomenal
super cut of of probably my least
favorite host on msnbc i find her to be
the most grating and the most dishonest
and the most strident nicole wallace
nicole wallace on msnbc has the audacity
to accuse conservatives of spreading
misinformation here is just a sliver
of the kind of misinformation you see
specifically from her
just one woman on just one network msnbc
donald trump to now investigate a
conspiracy theory about kovic coming
from a lab in wuhan this theory needs to
be investigated which is what president
biden is doing hunter biden's laptop
reveals emails we shouldn't look at it
as anything other than a russian
disinformation operation the hunter
biden laptop material is genuine the
murder of a police officer officer brian
sticknick was killed in the line of duty
they beat the capitol police officer to
death officer died of natural causes the
steele dossier it may be dirty but it
ain't fake
obviously the sealed i see is
discredited by far actually i mean this
is the lunatic response to what is a
very rational evidence-based fact-based
investigation fbi pleads guilty to
doctoring email what the report shows is
something that won't be surprising to
people that have spent a lot of time in
the federal government the report left
former officials aghast the fbi is
exonerated today it doesn't vindicate
anyone at the fbi who touched this they
are all absolved of any wrongdoing the
activities we found here don't indicate
anybody the trump administration cleared
peaceful black lives matter protesters
so the president could take a photo in
front of a church we did not find
evidence that federal agents used cs gas
this goes on for minutes this go and
this is just one little cut that one
journalist made about one
of the establishment propagandists on
just one of the establishment propaganda
networks just one
and i know if you're listening to this
show you probably have a healthy
skepticism of the establishment media
but even i
grizzled
jaded as i am watching that back to back
to back to back even i was shocked
the lies
that just just this one woman on just
this one network is spreading
and the crazy part is
they all do it
they all do it it's not just her and
it's not just that network
it's all of them
and they do it all the time and the
crazier part is tonight people even if
they saw that clip
tonight people are going to go home
or they're going to be walking in the
airport more likely if they're watching
cnn or msnbc and they're going to watch
that and the people in the in the
clothing with the serious faces are
going to go there and they're going to
say a bunch of bs again and a lot of
people are going to believe it
this is why this is why i don't
give any credence to the elon thing
i don't know whether elon propositioned
a masseuse or not
i i'm not even particularly interested
in this alleged incident that happened
six years ago
because
once you see it you can't unsee it
once you see
that the establishment press
are not there to report the news once
you see that the establishment press
have no regard for truth and they
actually seem to have a pretty strong
contempt for truth
when you see that they are only there to
advance
the democrat party line the liberal
political line the left the
establishment use whatever word you want
you
you become so repulsed
you become you it's even sort of
depressing because we all wish that we
could live in that time that we were
told existed in the past though it
probably never really did exist where we
could trust our newsmen where we all
just we listen you're entitled to your
own opinion but you're not entitled to
your own facts okay and we can all agree
on some basic things no we that doesn't
exist that doesn't exist the
institutions that are most demanding of
our trust are the most corrupt
and so i don't believe a damn word these
people say and every time one of them
parrots some line about how bad elon
musk is
my admiration for him increases
my my likelihood of supporting him
increases
significantly
the fake news is running
amok and it's at the very same time that
the government is trying to establish
new censorship boards to censor people
for saying the opposite of the
misinformation that they themselves are
spreading so now they're trying to set
up an enforcement mechanism in the
government to stop you from telling the
truth
now
some conservatives are pushing back
there was a delightful moment
in the senate yesterday when a democrat
senator gets up and starts spouting the
same dumb slogans that we've been
hearing now since donald trump was
elected which is that the republicans
beep boop the republicans are controlled
by putin beep beep boop they're the
pro-russia party beep beep beep boop and
it's totally contrary to the facts
and senator cruz gets up there because
because senator cruz i love the guy you
know i love the guy i host a podcast
with him
i know the guy pretty well and i know
one of his great strengths is
he knows the rules of the senate
he knows how to move levers of power
and he knows how to crush a guy in an
argument okay he knows how to find the
weakness in the argument he knows
exactly how to twist it that was his
career he was a prosecutor solicitor
general of texas argued cases before the
supreme court so he sees his opening and
he takes it
will the senator yield for questions
certainly
just a moment ago the senator from ohio
made reference to the alleged existence
of a so-called putin wing of the
republican party
i'd like to ask the senator from ohio is
it accurate that the senator from ohio
and 43 of his democratic colleagues
in january of this year
voted against sanctioning nordstrom 2
sanctioning russia sanctioning putin
despite the fact that ukraine begged the
senate to pass those sanctions
and putin invaded ukraine just days
after 44 democrats sided with russia and
putin
i take back my time i i've heard
no democrat talk i've heard nobody talk
about the
democrat putin wing of the democratic
party no democrat believes that
brutal
i love his uh could i just raise a
question oh sure yes the senator from
texas oh okay um
it's it's like out of my cousin vinnie
everything that guy just said is
complete bs he cruz gets up there and he
says
so you're making this allegation that
the republicans are the pro-putin party
is it not in fact the case that
you democrats are the ones who lifted
the sanctions on the nordstrom 2
pipeline which
ukrainian president zielenski himself
says was the cause of the war the
sanctions that i ted cruz and we the
republicans put into place
specifically to stop the invasion of
ukraine and that you guys lifted
and then what is this democrat senator
he says
uh
can i have a redo
can i take my time back i'm not going to
answer that and then the best part of it
all is the best answer he can muster
after he stammers for a little bit is
i've never heard anyone say that
the democrats are the pro-putin party
right you've never heard anyone say that
because you're all liars and hacks and
propagandists i've never heard anyone
say that on cnn right because cnn is
dishonest
i've never read that anywhere in the new
york times uh-huh right because the new
york times is are liars
the reporters and the editors less so
the reporters certainly the editors are
liars there
that's why you haven't heard it
but you'll notice cruz's question wasn't
about things people have said it was
about concrete actions
he says what huh what vote uh the vote
you took fella
okay all right back to the narrative no
more talk about actions no more talk
about things that people have actually
done we're just going to go back to the
narrative sometimes you can see those
cracks in the narrative one piece of the
democrat narrative
that has just collapsed because of
reality
came all the way back to the 2020
presidential debates when
president trump was hammering joe biden
over his family's obvious corruption
selling american influence to ukraine
selling american influence to china and
hunter biden
making a ton of money on this and
potentially giving a 10 kick back to the
big guy the big guy being his father
so you you had trump going after this
and joe biden who's usually pretty good
at giving himself some wiggle room he's
usually good at giving himself an out
he made a declarative statement he said
my son he couldn't say my son hasn't
made any money in ukraine because that
was so obvious and already proven
he said my son
has not made any money in china
my son has not made money in terms of
this thing about uh what are you talking
about china
in terms of what are you talking about
oh yeah china he hasn't made any money
nbc just came out with this report in
the space of five years 2013 to 2018
hunter biden inked two deals with
chinese business interests for a total
of 5.8 million dollars
this accounted for a little more than
half
of the money that his fake company
brought in during this time the company
brought in 11 million dollars the rest
of the money or a lot of the rest of the
money came from ukraine by the way but
5.8 million came from china so the
official line previously had been
hunter explored some business deals in
china but they didn't actually sign any
deals well not true he actually made
almost 6 million bucks from china for
what
for what for his expertise
for his paintings
for his chop suey recipe what what did
hunter biden give to china
that earned him almost 6 million bucks
he has nothing to offer
i was going to say he could offer crack
or hookers but he can't he actually
can't offer that people offer that to
him
so what did he offer he offered
access to his father he offered
the united states he offered the public
trust that's what he offered and he got
paid almost 6 million bucks for it
i no this is completely false this would
never ha and by the way when if you
suggested over the past two years that
the biden's made money in china you and
you said that on the show if you made a
declarative statement if you said that
on social media you would be hit with a
fact check fact check 20 000 pinocchio's
false
you would have your
your content suppressed by the social
media algorithms you would you would be
to some degree
pushed out of the public square
for saying something
that was completely true speaking of
sexual deviance hunter biden's the topic
speaking of sexual deviance a federal
judge has just ruled that an indiana
middle school
must let boys into the girls room
into the little girl's bathroom
federal judge
ruled this
on monday
judge tania walton pratt is her name an
obama appointee no surprise has rejected
the request of the martinsville school
district in martinsville indiana to
delay enforcement of an april ruling at
john r wood middle school that lets the
boys go into the girls room here's the
judge's
reasoning judge says this speculative
harm that could be caused by boys using
the girls room is both unsupported by
any evidence and appears questionable
given that the school district allows
other transgender students to use the
restrooms associated with their gender
identity so yeah the
the issue at hand
is whether or not
boys should be able to use the girls
room period
right it's not just in this one case but
in other schools and other parts of the
district maybe they can
you're saying this judge is saying the
speculative harm is both unsupported by
any evidence and appears questionable
remember last year
you remember the story that got glenn
younkin elected in virginia you remember
the story that the daily wire broke that
the establishment media tried to cover
up you remember how
a boy
raped a girl
14 year old 15 year old in a
girl's bathroom because the boy was
allowed to go into the bathroom a boy
who wore a skirt and then they covered
it up school covered it up put
transferred him to a different school
and then it happened again
speculative harm there's no no evidence
of this at all totally speculative
totally it's not questionable at all
it's a fact we see it with our own eyes
we see the news stories we hear
what happened we can listen to the
testimony of the girl's father
and you tell us no it's not happening at
all don't no don't believe it we're
listen we're so concerned we're so
concerned with sexual harassment that
we're going to try to take down elon
musk the minute he threatens our power
we're going to let boys into the girls
room to do all sorts of heinous crimes
that that's we're going to turn a blood
that's actually very important for
equity and justice and whatever
but we're believe us
on the news and on sexual morality and
on the public trust believe us we've got
your interests at heart do you if you
believe that i got a bridge in brooklyn
to sell you
so
here's the problem with a lot of the
establishment media shows they drone on
and on and on but that is not the case
with the sunday special this weekend
edition of the ben shapiro show ben
talks to the guests who hold different
points of view you think that mainstream
establishment shows would have ion
hersey ali matthew iglesias and jordan
peterson on as guests no way like
everything at the daily wire we are not
afraid to follow the truth wherever it
goes you'll find that with our upcoming
documentary with candace owens called
the greatest lie ever told a
hard-hitting expose about the death of
george floyd and the rise of blm you'll
also find it on this week's episode of
the sunday special with ben's guest
jonathan isaac he'll be discussing why i
stand the new book that he just released
with the daily wire isaac was the lone
nba player not to kneel for the national
anthem during a league-wide
demonstration in support of blm sunday
special is available sunday morning
wherever you get your podcast so tune in
you do not want to miss it we will be
right back with the mailbag brought to
you by puretalk
right now go to puretalk.com use promo
code knowles podcast
verizon att mobile are making one thing
clear they care about selling wokeness
more than wireless and so they are
making you fund their agenda with their
extremely overpriced contracts and their
hidden fees and you know this and i know
this every time you sign a cell phone
contract
they won't even give you the number very
often they'll say well it'll be
somewhere around here and it's so that
they can rip you off i've got great news
for you you don't need to trade in your
value system your beliefs for good phone
service you can choose puretalk instead
just as daily wire is offering
alternatives to woke entertainment media
puretalk is offering alternatives to
woke wireless networks puretalk's ceo is
a u.s veteran their service team is
located right here in america you do not
have to compromise on service you will
be on america's most reliable 5g network
for about half the cost unlimited talk
unlimited text six gigs of data for just
30 bucks a month i'm saving so much
money with pure talk i love my pure talk
phone they've got incredible deals on
the physical phones or you can keep your
phone keep your number it's super easy
puretalk.com right now shop for the plan
that's right for you that's puretalk.com
enter promo code noel's podcast to save
50 off your first month promo code
knowles podcast canon
w-l-e-s-p-o-d-c-a-s-t
all one word at puretalk.com puretalk is
simply smarter wireless
welcome back to my absolute favorite
time of the week when i get to hear from
you in the mailbag now i get to
literally hear from you in the voicemail
bag because this is now sponsored by
puretalk go to puretalk.com
enter promo code knowles podcast to save
50 off your first month if you want to
leave a voicemail back do it go to the
website click on the mail click on the
michael nola show click on the mailbag
button drop your audio file in there and
you could be heard on this show all
right first question
hey michael big fan of you personally
and the show
my question is
what should the republican party do
about the changing demographics um
i'm asking you and
not the other hosts because i think
you have a very important voice in the
republican party because i see you as
very loyal to the republican party but i
also see you as um very critical of the
republican party and so i think you're
an important voice in it
um i noticed that you
are very critical of the left
in the gaslighting of the country uh
regarding the changing demographics um
but i also noticed that you didn't deny
um the claims that they're making that
that um demographics are changing
um but surely you do not accept the
premise that demographics are destiny so
what should the rnc's strategy be
to make inroads in these minority
communities that are growing at a faster
rate than
the caucasian community
really good question
which you're absolutely not allowed to
ask or even suggest is happening unless
you're a leftist in which case you laugh
about it and brag about it for 20 years
this is a leftist political strategy
the libs don't care about hispanic
people the libs don't care about the
poor
foreign nationals who want to come into
the country the libs don't care about
any of that the libs care about power
and they are trying to make this about
race
or white supremacy or whatever
so that you shut up and so that you let
them take over the country and establish
what they believe will be a permanent
majority there is some reason for hope
that hispanics will over the course of
time become more republican you are
seeing that happen right now but it's
not happening fast enough
and so the the effect of mass migration
is exactly as the
left thought it would be which is that
it is benefiting democrats so what
should the republicans do the
republicans have to stop it
this is not a race thing
this is not about what defending white
supremacy this is about defending really
basic aspects of our law and political
culture
if you have a country
and then you open up the borders of that
country and you let
an unlimited number of foreigners pour
into the country and have
many of if not all of the rights of
american citizens you just don't have a
country anymore that's wrong it's wrong
for everybody who is in the country and
so we have to stop that
i always loved the squishy republicans
when they would try to push for amnesty
they would say
well what are we going to do with the at
the time they would say 11 million
illegal aliens in the country it's
probably much higher now what are we
what are we going to do with them we
can't just let them continue to remain
in this legally dubious state
and my answer is uh why not why can't we
we bro they broke the law
we're not
deporting them we should deport a great
many of them at the very least but we're
not we're not deporting them we're not
harassing them we're not throwing them
in gulags
why do we have to give them the rights
of citizenship why don't we just let
them be as they are they knew they knew
that that when they came into the
country they were told that was the
absolute best they could ever get they
signed up for it we have given them the
courtesy of not deporting them
so why do we also have to give them
voting we only have to give them voting
rights because the democrats think it'll
help them
so the first thing we have to do is just
stop it
the vast majority of americans want to
drastically reduce not just illegal
immigration but legal immigration too
we're just taking in too many people for
the last 60 years since the democrats
changed the immigration laws to give
themselves what they thought was what
they expect to be a permanent majority
we have seen the largest movement of
people ever in recorded history
that's not sustainable
and it's not just the democrats that you
say i'm a very loyal republican i think
i'm probably the most loyal republican
one of the most loyal republicans in the
conservative movement but as you say i'm
also probably one of the most critical
people
of the republican party in the movement
because i i i know those things seem
like they're in conflict but i don't
think they are i understand politics is
a team sport and if you want to pretend
that you're high and mighty and above it
all you're not going to actually
accomplish anything in politics that's
why you need parties but
the other part of that is if the party
is not doing anything and the party is
actually in many ways allowing the left
to destroy the country well then that
party's not worth anything either so you
need the loyalty but you need the tough
love too and there is an economic
incentive for the business republicans
to encourage mass migration because
as many people have pointed out we have
a
below replacement birth rate in america
so you would have a declining population
if not for mass migration and that would
not be great for the entitlement
programs and that would not be great for
gdp and that would not be great for the
capitalists in
running the corporations and so they
encourage that sort of thing too and the
democrats get what they want which is
their
political power and the
big corporations get what they want
namely to
keep
labor
wages low and keep the gdp up but the
american people don't get to keep their
traditions their culture their political
institutions their system of law and so
we need to assert our rights as well
you don't
you don't need to be afraid of being
called a racist or a white supremacist
or whatever they're going to call you
that anyway you don't need to make this
issue about racial essentialism or
identitarianism or whatever you just
need to point out hey
you libs are pursuing a very
specific political strategy to
gain political power by changing the
electorate and we're not going to let
you do that it's a cynical strategy it's
an opportunistic strategy and we're
going to say no
next question
hi michael how young is too young to
start investing yourself into politics
i am 13 and started listening to all of
the daily wire shows every day after
school the start of february after
finding my dad on the website reading an
article
i have a 150 plus iq and i have a knack
for debate
am i ready to with my dad watching from
a safe distance do they prove me wrong
out in public or should i wait a few
years
thanks love the show very kind you
should wait a few years you are too
young you are not too young to be
involved in politics you could run for
student government that'll teach you
more about politics than any sort of
debates you do
out in public
you could maybe get involved
volunteering for a campaign
not sure what the rules are depending on
age but you could maybe get involved in
a campaign if you really want to
in some
more private capacity i do not think you
should make yourself a public figure at
13.
the very fact that you're telling me how
high your iq is
shows you the risks of
of going out in public because just as a
political matter when you tell people
how high your iq is they don't like that
very much so i'm not even denying that
you have a very iq you seem obviously
very precocious very intelligent you're
listening to all these shows at a very
young age that's very very impressive
but
you are too young to be a political
figure and furthermore even if you have
a very high iq you you almost certainly
don't know a lot of things you just
haven't had enough time to learn a lot
of things
i'm talking about book learning but then
especially experience and politics is a
lot about experience and politics is a
lot about relationships and politics is
a lot about a maturity that can only
come with time that actually can't be
learned in a book or cannot be intuited
merely through the use of your
unfettered reason so i would encourage
you i know i was a precocious young kid
too i
have been a political
animal since i was very young i
campaigned in my first grade classroom
for bob dole that is not a joke i really
i don't know why i like bob dole so much
but i really liked him and i i've been
interested in politics from a very young
age
if you become a public figure when
you're really really young you will make
mistakes you will say things that you
ultimately will not believe you will
make you will embarrass yourself in many
ways because that's just what teenagers
do teenagers embarrass themselves that's
the way the their brains work that's the
way their behavior is
almost without exception
wait
read a lot of books
listen to the podcasts pay attention to
politics do all of those things figure
out what you really believe get a little
intro get a little experience behind the
scenes
and then you will be in such a much
better position when you're older when
you're i'm not even saying that much
older but when you're
19
20 when you're still very young but
you'll have a little bit more
a little bit more experience a little
bit more knowledge
and you will be less likely to
make errors that in our age of social
media and the internet is forever that
could really damage your future
next question
hi mr knowles my name is kyle i'm a
conservative from chicago and my
question is well when discussing
abortion with a leftist they will often
say you know well it's a woman's body
it's feeding the baby keeping it alive
inside her womb
et cetera you've probably heard it
before you definitely have
uh because well yeah i guess you know if
you take a baby out of the womb at an
early stage it probably won't survive so
i'm kind of at a loss as to what to say
to this
so of course i have come to the expert
how would you respond to this argument
thanks a ton love the show michael great
question the question is how do you
respond to those abort it was a little
muddled uh what he said but i think what
i heard was
the the baby needs the mother the baby
needs the mother can't survive outside
the woman so the mother has the right to
kill the baby i don't understand how
that second part follows from the first
part
unless you believe that we don't have
any obligations to anyone else unless
you adopt some insane a historical
philosophically incoherent position
that we are all just pure individuals
who can do whatever we want with our own
bodies at any given time
and we have no obligations to anyone
else
a mother has obligations to her baby
let's say the baby's born
goes through the whole pregnancy the
baby's born the baby's now six months
old outside the womb
and the mother
leaves the baby in a car
all right his mother's going to go
grocery shopping leaves the baby in a
car by the time the mother comes out
someone sees the babies in the car that
mother would be arrested
for neglect for child abuse
but it's the mother's body the mother
can do whatever the mother wants no the
mother has obligation so if the mother
has an obligation to the baby outside of
the womb if the mother can be prosecuted
for what the mother does or does not do
or just withholds from the baby outside
of the womb
why would the mother not have
obligations to the baby inside of the
womb at least the very basic obligation
not to kill the baby
it's it's such a disingenuous argument
from the libs because the lips say look
the baby isn't viable the baby isn't
autonomous the baby can't survive
without the mother and so the mother has
every right to withhold that support
okay that isn't that isn't a good
argument but let's just accept that
premise for a second a baby can survive
outside the womb these days at 21 weeks
sometimes
so okay pro-abortion person are you
willing to ban abortion after 21 weeks
no
none of them are going to do that why
the baby can survive outside the womb
now so all the mother's got to do is
just
deliver
the live baby the mother's going to have
to deliver a dead baby if she gets an
abortion the baby's got to come out
somehow so the mother can either deliver
a dead baby or a live baby so if the
baby can survive outside the womb
why not just skip the step of the
abortionist killing the baby and deliver
the baby you don't ever have to think
about the baby again would you be
willing to give that up no
they would never do it and shows you how
disingenuous they are all right next
question
hey michael
so i have made some huge improvements to
my life in the last year as i finally
escaped the left and the toxic
ideologies that i adopted during college
it started with me watching jordan
peterson and i have gradually found
myself becoming more and more
conservative
i feel hugely grateful to the daily wire
for helping me make sense of the
brainwashing and misery i experienced as
a leftist atheist
i even recently ended my relationship
with my liberal fiancee because it was
clear that he and i no longer had shared
goals or values my family and friends
are understandably really confused by my
political and religious transformation
so my question is
do you have any advice for new
conservatives
huge fan of the show thanks
i do i have lots of advice for new
conservatives
you've already done probably the most
difficult thing that you would have to
do
that is
the right thing to do
i am not saying that
you can't have couples with mixed
politics i'm not even saying you can't
have couples with mixed religion
although that's much harder
but what you're describing your
disagreement with your fiance your
ex-fiancee is not doesn't sound like
it's a disagreement over marginal tax
rates it sounds like it's a disagreement
on really fundamental questions
what is society what is the human person
what is a marriage
you need to agree on that
before you get married
and if you don't agree on that and you
come to realizations later some people
do that you have to work very hard to
make sure you get on the same page you
both have to be doing the same thing
that is very important so you've you've
come to this realization that the
liberal secular worldview is just crap
and it's gonna give people a bad life
and so now you're pursuing something
different your family will think you're
crazy your friends will think you're
crazy my advice for you is to be patient
with them
to be confident in the decisions that
you've made and to be curious so that
you don't you don't merely remain
where you are in your thought you you've
realized that what you were doing was
wrong and what you previously believed
is wrong you've realized that and you've
saw it and you can't unsee it so now
you're kind of following this and you're
you started listening to jordan peterson
then i guess you started listening to me
and then you started reading things and
watching things keep going keep going
and let that deepen
politically certainly let that deepen
and then culturally let that deepen and
then ultimately religiously let that
deepen you mention that you your
religious views have changed as well of
course all human conflict is theological
it always comes back to religion follow
that as well patience is a virtue that's
patience for the
friends and family who rightly are
shocked by what's going on
confidence you've seen it
you can't unsee it
and then
the curiosity
to and humility to continue to follow
that see where it goes that would be my
advice well done i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show see you
next week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael noel show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin